la première battle guillaume genton à
contre dial
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je marchais avec un poteau avec ça elle
c'est un truc de ouf j'ai raté de manier
ouais au genre lancée je suis préparé
je
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
là
j
[Applaudissements]
je mets de meilhan nappage et les
camions man énormément guillaume mais
j'ai laissé son soutien les classes
après des danses très très bien c'est
dans ce qu'on fait que tu la perds 10
danses dit non je fais danse avec les
stars
[Applaudissements]
et
lille
je vais
faire chanter
[Applaudissements]
sur steam il fait la même dans quel que
soit ce qui met bas mais mylène andré
lassalle chorégraphique icaunaise
voilà badiane fraîchement sortis ils
sont bons allez vivement que les boîtes
de nuit ouvre voilà jean castex déconne
pas on va alors devoir alors demandé
voit déjà la norme est toujours là
je
[Applaudissements]
1000mercis chez moi j'ai pas benjamin tu
te sens ja oui je peux pas grand danseur
mais ça fait le bonheur de pouvoir
danser
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais chic junte à la dernière émission
et commence à se frotter à moi j'ai eu
peur alors belime ça fait très longtemps
que j'ai pas vu danser oui alors je
pense avec une béquille vous savez moi
je vais doucement creux benjamin
castaldi aussalesa l'alchimie
ouais
et moi
cette fête nationale à la barben
exactement sur la dame américaine saleh
pour danser
[Applaudissements]
merci savait qu'ils allaient lâcher
comme ça nicolas pernikoff
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quoi
les mecs qui volent ils présentent leurs
excuses
c'est un truc de géraldine incroyable
regrette michael john michael douglas
dans ma titine sans rigoler
c'était énorme c'est une autre
génération qui donne à noël je vous ai
trouvé exceptionnel un monument de la
danse aller mais on a fait toute cette
séquence pour voir des films
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ouais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors
est ce que je vais te couper l'eau
présente dans les jeux
jacques m d'ouverture hier les
changements clés c'était tout pêcheur
beaucoup plus au compteur je ne vois
rien voir mais ce bourse a toujours
proposé de tout cacher
[Applaudissements]